كم مره نسيت اين وضعت هاتفك في المنزل او
وين مفتاح سيارتك او ان كنت قد اغلقت
الباب ام لا او حتى كنت تتحدث في موضوع
وفجاه نسيت اسماء الاشخاص من حولك كلها
امور عاديه تحدث لدى الكثيرين في الحياه
اليوميه لكن الواضح مشاهدينا انا ظاهره في
ازدياد والسؤال هل يعد هذا النسيان هو نوع
من انواع
اطباء دماغ واعصاب وافقه تقرير مطول
لصحيفه الامارات اليوم قالوا انهم محاصرون
بعدد ضخم من الزيارات من قبل الشباب
ببساطه شباب كثيرون خائفون من اصابتهم
بالمرض
هؤلاء الاطباء توقعوا تزايد عدد المصابين
بالزعيمر اعتبارا من عمر الخمسه وستين
عاما
لا تقلق عزيزي الشاب هذه الاعراض التي
لديك تسمى الخرف الكاذب وفق الاطباء ضروري
انكم صايحين لانه في شيء غلط الكل بيسال
سؤال واحد شو العلاقه ما بين كورونا وهذا
النسيان
هل اليوم لما اخذنا اللقاحات لكورونا هي
السبب بانه قاعد تخلينا ننسى باعتباري انا
لسه شاب لا طبعا ما في ربط بين مطعوم
الكورونا والنسيان صارت شماعه طبعا لا ما
في اي علاقه بيناتهم
شكل رسمي يعني ما في دراسات تثبت بانه في
علاقه ولكن هل يمكن ان يكون في علاقه ما
بين اي لقاح وما بين تدهور الانشطه
الدماغيه للانسان نعم صحيح هلا مرض
الكورونا او لقاحات مرض الكورونا قد تسرع
من بعض اعراض مرضى الخرف يعني اللي بكون
عنده خراف او بكون بدايه الخرف وجود
كورونا وجود الالتهابات او وجود المطاعيم
مع
اللي بصير منها انه قد تزيد اعراض الخرف
واعراضه جميعها طيب يعني دكتور اليوم
واحده من اعراض اللقاح حينما يعني اخذناه
كان على الاقل كنت في حاله غير طبيعيه انه
هذا مطعوم جديد دخل على الجسم ربما يعني
بعدم التركيز وهو ما دفع الناس الى تفكر
انه قد يكون بسبب هذه هذه اللقاحات هي ما
سببت الخرف الكاذب الخرف الكاذب او السوده
ديمنشيان هي طبعا شفناها كتير حالات هلا
جديده صارت تيجي على العيادات عنا خصوصا
تحت سن الخمسين تحت سن الخمسين ما كنا
نشوف بهذه العيادات عنا مرضى بيجوا يحكوا
لنا احنا بلشنا ننسى احنا صرنا ما في
تركيز الوظائف اللي كنا نسويها صارت تاخذ
معنا وقت اطول صار الكل يذكرنا باخر سنتين
ثلاثه شهدت زياده ملحوظه عنا حتى في
العيادات ولكن يعني الخرف الخرف طبعا في
في اسباب كثيره هي طبعا لهاي الشغلات هلا
الخرف الكاذب عشان نحكي على الخرف الكاذب
او السدد منشيه هي اعراض تحاكي او تشابه
الخرف الحقيقي ولكن مع فروقات طبعا
العوارض او الاهم الاسباب للخرف الكاذب
الضغط النفسي الاكتئاب التوتر القلق
الوسواس القهري الوسواس المرضي الوسواس
النظافي كل هذه الاعراض قد تؤدي الى اعراض
القرف الكاذب من نقصان بالذاكره والنقصان
بالتركيز من عدم القدره على القيام
بالوظائف